hi i'm catherine mccord and today on pro
tips from pro chefs i'm going to be
showing you
road trip snacks that are going to save
you as you head on your destination and
make sure that your bellies are full
something we already know america loves
road trips can we talk about road trips
next
[Music]
one of our favorite travel recipes are
these cucumber stackers they're also
perfect if you are gluten free because
there's no bread in them so you can take
a cucumber persian or english cucumber
whatever you like you can keep the skin
on or skin off i like the skin on
especially with the persians because
they are much thinner than an english
cucumber and you want to cut them about
a half an inch and just remember this is
your bread not exactly the bread that
you might be used to
but it gives a little bit of crunch and
you get a vegetable in there too then
we're going to take some cheese
and some turkey so you can put them side
by side on top of each other whatever
you like now is the fun part cookie
cutters they are not just for christmas
i use them all year round in different
kinds of shapes these are kind of
flowers and clouds and stars but again
use what you've got so i just take them
like this
super fun you can get your kids involved
if you want because it's a really fun
one
all right and again like different
shapes and when they're eating them you
can have them say like what kind of
shape do you think is in there because
on a long trip you want to keep everyone
as entertained as possible okay so
you're gonna put a cucumber and put your
star on top and then you can just place
them right on top like that
and you can use other kinds of deli meat
too you could use ham pastrami roast
beef same thing goes with the cheese i
like to use cheddar but you could also
use mozzarella colby munster swiss
anything you enjoy all right so i've got
my
turkey and i'm just gonna put my
cheese right on top
all you do is put
the cucumber right on top
and that
is a cucumber stacker only three
ingredients the perfect bite-sized treat
to get a vegetable in there and protein
as you're traveling and
make sure that no one gets hangry on
your road trip and don't forget if you
have scraps like this feel free to throw
them in a sandwich now and keep your
cucumber stackers for later peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches are totally
yesterday i am talking about peanut
butter and jelly pop tarts these are
homemade only three ingredients you need
pie crust that you can make yourself or
you can buy prepared in the refrigerator
section of your grocery and then i just
fill them these little squares about two
inches by three inches with a teaspoon
of peanut butter a teaspoon of jelly you
bake them up in a 400 degree oven until
they're nice and golden like this now
the fun part though comes with the glaze
so i like to put one on a surface and
then i've got a little bit of powdered
sugar here after all you're on a road
trip and it's all about making it as fun
as possible so in the powdered sugar i
like to put some food color and then
you're going to just add in a little
milk now you want to do this a little
bit at a time because we're just trying
to make a really beautiful glaze and ask
your kids what color they want blue
green yellow
they can play with their primary colors
all right just slowly stir stir stir
adding just a little bit of that milk at
a time because you want to make sure
that your glaze is thick enough you
don't want it to be too runny all right
so stir it oh yes that's what we're
talking about
look at that pretty pretty color
and you just want it like that kind of a
consistency just thick enough but
spreadable at the same time and then
we're just gonna put a little that glaze
let it drip drip drip so it doesn't make
a big mess
and then we're just going to spread it
right on like to use a spoon because it
makes it easier just to spread it all
around and just that extra bit of
sweetness on top makes it fun to look at
but also to enjoy tasting and then
just to really up the ante i like to put
some sprinkles on top just a few to give
it a little pop look how cute those are
they're like the perfect summertime
treat
at any given time i have four boxes of
cereal in my pantry with just about this
much left over so these cereal bars are
the perfect use for that kind of
leftover cereal i dump them in i add a
ton of peanut butter or any kind of nut
or seed butter that you like a little
bit of coconut oil which is the greatest
tip to kind of keeping them together
and then some oats so that you get that
whole grain goodness i put everything
into this nine by nine inch pan always
line your pans with parchment paper just
like this that way they pull right out
and makes clean up and cutting them a
breeze so just take that parchment
and then take a serrated knife and we're
just going to cut them like this
another great tip is if you feel like
you need to head out on your road trip
and you want to make these really fast
just put them in the freezer because
they'll set up really quick and then we
can just turn turn turn
and cut them
oh
look at that
not only are they absolutely delicious
but look at that any kind of cereal you
like is going to work for these on the
go bars i don't know many kids who don't
love cereal but who wants to take milk
with their cereal on a road trip these
cereal bars are a ton more fun have a
lot of protein in them and
no mess
last but definitely not least is my
super healthy granola i have a batch of
this with me at all times why because it
is like hearty you can put it in
parfaits but i'm going to tell you my
tip for getting these huge chunks that
look more like granola bars than they do
granola so after you add in all of your
ingredients you're going to allow it to
spread out
bake it in a 250 degree oven for about
an hour and 45 minutes take it out and
totally let it cool because that cooling
process allows it to get nice and crispy
stick together so when it comes out of
the oven it's in these huge chunks you
can break into smaller pieces put in a
bag and that for me is the best
on-the-go snack the reason i love this
granola and making it is so much better
than store bought you can control the
ingredients in here you get a lot more
bang for your buck and it's not too
sweet there's no refined sweeteners in
it so it's just that perfect kiss in
every single bite
for more pro tips head to the
drewbarramoreshow.com
pro tips and if you make any of these
recipes on the go tag me at welicious
drew barramore show thanks for having me
drew this was so much fun
[Music]